According to The Economist,
democracy continued its sharp decline in 2020.
Elected autocrats haven't risen independently
around the world; rather, they learn from one another,
sharing best practices and corrupting
judicial independence and rigging elections.
It's now clear that autocrats benefit
from a dictator's playbook.
It's time for democracies around the world
to author their own democratic playbooks.
Exploiting pre-existing anxieties in society,
electoral re-engineering,
corrupting the media, jailing political opponents,
and constitutional reforms to
consolidate these gains—all are key tools
in the dictator's playbook. Democracies should use
multilateral forums to put autocrats on notice.
Sanctions, diplomatic isolation, shoring
up civil society organizations,
and targeted trade measures are but a few of
the tools democracies should use to fight back.
Further, democracies must reform the UN
Human Rights Council and bring
the democrats' playbook within the confines
of a multilateral grouping, like the
proposed D10, to give it greater meaning.
Competing against autocrats
without a playbook is bound to fail.
Should the United
States and other leading democracies
work to thwart the dictator's playbook
with an offensive plan of their own?
Let us know in our poll. Also, let us know
what other topics you'd like our scholars
to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.